[Música]
olá pessoal é porque me conhece eu sou
damaso daqui me conhece eu também sou da
amazônia
então o que eu vou falar aqui com vocês
é normalmente a algumas pessoas ficam
surpresas
outras ficam assustadas alguns me chamam
de herege
alguns até concorda comigo então é mais
dificilmente alguém fica indiferente
então se você ficar indiferente nos
próximos 17 minutos e 31 30 29 segundos
a culpa é minha não do do tema
normalmente eu falo é disto pra pra
físicos porque eu sou físico é o fiz o
mestrado doutorado na física eu dou aula
o curso física eu eu pesquiso física
também o público normalmente são físicos
é tem os químicos vez em quando os
biólogos teve uma vez que eu fiquei mais
animado com o auditório lotado tipo hoje
assim eu vou ter um público maior os
calouros atração física que errar o
auditório então ela toma aqui no caminho
errado né não
belletti continental então o pessoal
fica meio bravo assim então não gosto
que eu vou falar porque desconstrói
aquilo que eles têm mais carinho que é
um sem a ciência ou pelo menos uma visão
de ciência
então se tiver algum físico químico ahq
que bravo foram alguma coisa em mim eu
torço pra pela mira ruim né porque não
consigo enxergar nada então espero que
ninguém acerte
então vou falar aqui eu vou falar sobre
é tentar desconstruir uma ideia perigosa
de ciência para a própria capa aqui dá
que vocês estão vendo que é esse
e se esse personagem o parque já foi
perguntar é esse personagem que é um
padre que contribuiu para a construção
do mastro uma das teorias que é mais
caras aos físicos que o big bang
então é aqui que começa a construir um
pouco a idéia é separar
são de atividade isolada ciência uma
coisa quase sacrossanta então o papel
aqui então
então uma coisa quase tocam o santa que
essa que é uma uma coisa sobre humana
bastante exata então aqui já começa a
construir um pouco é como é que um padre
veio para a história então é essa etapa
começará a construir essa idéia
então antes começavam tentar ler algumas
notícias muito muito recorrentes na nova
de comunicação por exemplo está pequeno
então vim para cá há evidências que o
santo sudário é uma farsa
há quatro tipos de prova científica
prova científica uma balela
não existe prova científica ainda vai
discutir daqui a pouco isso sempre fala
em prova científica
só tem uma atitude a fazer que da pessoa
então não acredita nisso
essa aqui está aqui quem é que se alguém
tem dúvida que essa notícia pode ajudar
a ciência comprova é melhor está só do
que mal acompanhado
então quem está a dúvida em dúvida em
largar o esposo ou esposa aqui pode
ajudar né
mas essa minha preferida cientista prova
a existência de deus ninguém um dos
prêmios mais cobiçados
essa é a minha pessoa porque que essas
notícias mostravam que ela nos mostram
ela mostra o seguinte que hoje em dia
tal qual o senso comum entende a ciência
a ciência passou a da chancela a todas
as outras crenças que quer dizer com
isso para eu acreditar em deus não basta
ter uma crença que tem a sua
cristianismo tem 2 mil e poucos anos e
charlie 12 em poucos anos o o judaísmo
mais ou um pouco menos mas não basta ter
uma crença é acreditar nisso tentei
chancela da ciência
quero levar minha esposa não basta o teu
que era esposa não tinha chance ao da
ciência que minhota só do acompanhado
então é uma coisa meio meio um padrão de
excelência né então
o que que é isso de onde vem isso só que
isso é da onde que é isso
isso vem o seguinte no mito vem uma
crença mal mal construída e que se que
as pessoas acreditam do que a que existe
método científico que existe uma maneira
de fazer ciência que o cientista é um
sujeito racional que age de acordo com
uma métodos e padrões não existe
desculpa decepcionado não consigo ver
uma deve ter umas casas feitas aqui
sempre tem que quando falou que não tem
médico científico não existe mais
científico é balela mais científico
cientistas a ajem de muitas maneiras e
muitas maneiras que não admitem
por exemplo quem tá nos estudos
pesquisas abi que inveja todo ciência na
verdade de e falta do dinheiro produz
ciência sobra de eficiência briga produz
ciência até de voz por docência
depois é verdade mas então tudo produz
ciência dentro de sites com textos então
a ciência é tem vários padrões várias
maneiras de de se produzir por exemplo a
ascensão que o estudo que é física
a maneira como eu produzo física que o
estudo física eu sou médico o uso há
algumas como nos meus pares e avaliam
como oa como eu consigo não dinheiro de
editais é completamente diferente do meu
colega físico que trabalha um lado
então não tem essa história de médici em
ti fico esse método científico ele ele
construiu que uma base sobre humana um
quase uma aura paciência porque se a
pessoa age como método científico age de
maneira racional ela está acima da
humanidade ela tá fazendo uma coisa
atenção à palavra exata é uma ciência
exata
então eu não sou humana só exato eu sou
físico não é essa ideia está passando
por trás
então então essa idéia de entender que a
ciência é feito de uma maneira uniforme
racional e lógica da uma base sobre
humana paciência que vem o padrão de
excelência então tá
essa base sobre humana então que é exata
é uma maneira segura de produzir
conhecimento não é fruto do conhecimento
eu posso te falar da minha mulher porque
a ciência diz que é melhor tal só eu
posso acreditar em deus porque entrou
bastante deus eu não preciso outras
coisas
só que muito cuidado aqui
essa é uma maneira de ver ciência é uma
maneira de ver ciência que é muito comum
senso comum está presente no fantástico
está presente no repórter está por
exemplo descobri o talvez os dois maio o
pai fã de pink e controle coletivo aqui
então tá mais banais que não esqueça
aqui então voltou não
então não precisa mais então a volta ou
então essa maneira de deficiência é a
maneira que está presente no senso comum
os dois maiores divulgadores de ciência
na que a gente tem hoje em dia no mundo
que é o newtom tyson eo e xandão quem
seguir eles propagam essa visão de
ciência essa visão decência é propagada
também por maior doador cientista
brasileiro que marcelo gleiser que tinha
um produto fantástico então essa madeira
é uma maneira muito comum de se enxergar
só que é uma maneira de deficiência que
a gente pela maneira racionalista
deficiência
a maneira essa maneira racionalista ela
diminui a grande grande complexidade ea
grande beleza do fazer ciência ela tenta
separar a ciência das pessoas é como se
o cientista fosse o cientista e não é
uma pessoa comum
só que isso nos leva a perguntar então o
que a ciência eo que tem de tão
formidável respeitassem a ciência a
desculpa decepcionar muita gente ciência
é um grande
de mito porque é um grande mito
se não tem médico científico não têm
nada em comum nas diversas ciências
então a ciência nada mais é do que uma
lista que eu ponho aquilo que eu tenho
mais carinho
por exemplo eu gosto de biologia na
minha lista
eu gosto de história na minha lista não
michel expulso do palco da história
então agora não gosta ou sociologia
mentira eu gosto mas só pra tá gravando
música gosto então então eu não gosto
elogia então a tecnologia não entra na
minha lista é eu gosto de vodu entra na
minha lista mas que que o que que tem
comum nos elementos de uma lista de
ciência a pessoa faz não têm nada em
comum têm mais contraditórias dentro uma
própria ciência que a física depois
contraditórias e se eu votasse as ditas
em exatas quer física biologia e química
não tem nada a ver uma coisa com a outra
então que a ciência é um mito uma lista
que eu construo o que tem de tão
formidável experiência
a crença que esse mito existe a crença
que esse mito é produzido assim então a
quando eu falo um produto científico é
assim eu tô dizendo que a apple
científico porque ele foi produzido pelo
mec científico agora muito importante é
uma questão que é preciso refletir a
seguinte qualquer dito produto
científico não é produto só da ciência
por exemplo o computador não foi
produzido só pelas ditas ciência da
influência de todo o conhecimento humano
aqui tem como influência da história da
infância geografia influência do do
influente então todas as com todos os
níveis de conhecimento contribuem
produto que alguns chamam de produção
científica
então não existe nada isolado a ciência
dita ciência não é uma entidade isolada
o cientista exato não vive numa torre de
marfim
a religião influencia a a a biologia
influencia tudo influencia então quando
eu falo que
a oposto à ciência funciona porque nós
temos prova a para o que prova o que que
é o do científico da onde vem isso prova
que é a essência isolada não tem senso
do lada então é essa é esse
essa foi essa excelência dita da ciência
na verdade é um convencimento do público
que a esse mito ciência ainda não tem
nada de vocês que eu só é sempre essa
hora tem uns três quatro e levando
embora ninguém foi ainda né então beleza
então então a popularidade é fruto do
convencimento do público
agora é importante isso a ciência
college enxerga a ciência de uma maneira
não é um racionalista ela ganha muito
mais graça
ela ganha muito mais importância ela
ganhar muito mais charme
aguardamos as palavras porque ela é
feita por gente ela é feita por pessoas
físicas a ss humana biologia é sem ser
humana química fs humana
o que isso quer dizer é falha física é
falha biologia falha química falha
ciência não produz conhecimento certo
ciência certeza eu posso contestar o
conhecimento científico eu não devo
acreditar num cientes que diz o que pode
ser fatal mulher porque a presença conta
comprovando ó acredita em deus porque a
ciência comprova balela eu tenho direito
de escolher uma tradição eu tenho
direito de manter uma tradição
então se eu enxergo a ciência dessa
forma eu entendo a ciência como uma
construção humana e ela fica muito mais
bonita do que uma ciência racionalista
ela fica muito mais plural ela fica
muito mais interessante e fica muito
mais acessível a ciência não é
inalcançável
a ciência não é pra gênios assim se à
época todo mundo é procure zinho que
está fazendo o primeiro ano do ensino
médio e quer fazer física mas é também
o leitor leitor da superinteressante 70
setenta anos todos podem participar da
ciência ou produzindo ciência ou
ajudando a desenvolver a ciência com as
suas críticas e aceitando ou não os
produtos que os cientistas querem vender
todo mundo participar desse processo
então não há nenhuma ideia por mais
antiga ou absurda que não beba existir
não debater o direito de se desenvolver
porque isso eu que estudou ciência eu
faço questão da michelle da história
desenvolveu a história eu faço questão
da amélia estudar moda e desenvolver
moda eu faço questão do herói loki
desenvolver sua arte porque isso vai
ajudar a minha ciência
isso vai ajudar a minha obra porque eu
vou ser contaminado por todos eles
se todas as tradições culturais tiveram
direito de desenvolver eu voltar vou tá
dando um tiro dentro porque eu vou estar
ajudando conhecimento humano a se
desenvolver e tudo isso vai ajudar minha
própria obra
se fechar a ciência nela mesmo sem
influência nenhuma ela mais três chances
e 600 fechando se fechando
vai-se isolantes lã solando e washington
do que uma crença na casamata física
cresça matar física leva a religiões ou
seja se a ciência fosse o que os
analistas acreditam que ela é na verdade
ela é uma forma de religião e piora uma
forma de religião que eles topavam que
seja melhor do que todas as outras
então é um perigo está nessa visão
nacionalista essa visão é só na
eficiência que é o senso comum nos traz
é um perigo para a própria sociedade
porque os analistas a estimarem qualquer
um que não siga a ciência como místico
ignorante
vou dar um exemplo clássico que todo
mundo passou já por exemplo eu vou ao
médico
o médico diz assim tu tem que fazer tal
tratamento médico pede assim não vou
fazer vou fazer um trabalho
alternativo porque mais do que baixar de
mim um bicho ignorante né
não é isso se ao invés de fazer um exame
é vazio resolvi fazer uma uma selar um
tratamento com florais chamado início do
ano antes sim vejo é eu querer um
tratamento com radioterapia eu procurei
um xamã
eu sou miss ignorante mas não é
exatamente isso que os antigos
religiosos falar o que não não professar
sua fé eram mistos ignorantes
então essa visão nacionalista cada vez
mais se alinha uma forma de ciência
então
na visão dele a ciência já que o santa o
pneus confortáveis só com aval da
ciência e outras tradições são
entendidas como pagãs expedição isso é
um perigo
perigo mesmo está passando então só que
a ciência que eu tô falando com vocês é
a ciência que a gente enxerga na
história da ciência é muito mais bem
construído que essa visão limitada
decência porque eu achei de falhas
ela é cheia de contradições ela é cheia
de nuances
ela é muito mais interessante então ela
é muito mais bonita de se ver
e porque é muito boa de se ver porque
ela falha ela não é ela não produz
verdade saná por duas certezas nenhuma
teoria científica é comprovada porque
toda teu acesa com se constrói ajustando
seus erros ou os deuses que a comunidade
entenda como erros ao longo da história
tão tudo em ciência é passageiro tudo em
ciência é provisório tudo ensina
superado nossas teorias mais caras hoje
em dia vão ser tema de de aula do 1º ano
do ensino médio que 200 anos mecânica
quântica vai ser matéria fácil daqui a
200 anos
como ninguém vai falar pra saber então
ficam verdade
então a idéia é o que quero passar para
vocês
a ciência é de todos e para todos todos
podem fazer poder ciência ou podem
julgar um produto dito científico porque
a ciência não é melhor do que outras
tradições a ciência uma dentre muitas
tradições
a ciência não gera verdades absolutas
indiscutíveis
as conclusões provisórias os resultados
e os cientistas devem ser questionadas
ea última ideia rapidinho a seguinte
qual o perigo disso se eu acreditar que
uma tradição que se baseia em seguir
regras que seriam mais científico é
excelência eu vou acreditar que a
excelência na sociedade é seguir regras
a excelência da sociedade é aceitá lo
palavra de autoridade
isso é um perigo enorme velocidade livre
na visão do analista de ciência é um
perigo para as aproximar do livro então
de ver nós como cidadão é contestar essa
ideia sua eficiência e que querer
participar desse produto ciência que
lhes cai tanto dólar
obrigado
[Aplausos]